Eric Boss here with another new  rockstars hot take our Wolverine and  Deadpool gonna get arrested by the time  variance Authority Hugh Jackman just  went on Sirius XM referring to quote a  device they have in the Marvel world of  moving around timelines now Jackman  could have been referring to a literal  technological device or more likely a  plot device it's probably a plot device  I get it but either way this plot device  only exists because of Loki in the TVA  it's the only ongoing narrative  mechanism in the MCU for manipulating  timelines right now this plus Ryan  Reynolds flirting with missed minutes on  Twitter make me think that Reynolds and  Jackman might connect to the Loki corner  of the MCU we don't even need an actual  season 2 Cameo just a prison cell or a  booking document with Wade Wilson's name  listed for Wolverine that bookie number  better be  six oh one let me know what you think  And subscribe to new rockstars